mais bon appétit merci oui bonne à pâte
pour ne pas le côté peau qu ils centrent
faire une bonne pâte à pizza maison un
défi pour bien des gens pour le chef
david et bat salies
tout est une question d'adaptation
depuis que la pandémie a commencé j'ai
commencé à faire la piste aux jeux
n'étaient pas équipés pour faire un
paysage et parfois au bois je vais pas
vous fier non plus alors j'ai ai
concocté canton mes frères et soeurs on
est quatre chacun il a sa recette que sa
dérive dans la recette de
notre mère elle a toujours fait une
pizza une fois par semaine et si on paie
déjà sur plaque et c'est quelque chose
que chacun il peut faire chez lui ce que
j'ai fait j'ai pris sa recette je les
aurais fait sur la base je ne m'en fous
ça m'a pris deux gsm au troisième c'est
est ce que le monde
[Musique]
si j'ai mis des ingrédients qu'on peut
trouver n'importe où alors vraiment
c'est facile on a de la farine tout aux
âges vont utiliser dans la levure humide
celle des boulangeries ou sinon c'est
raté
les lèvres sèches comme le siège est à
vienne après ça on a du sel on à du
sucre
moi j'aime beaucoup m du miel et après
ça c'est de l'eau ça doit être un petit
peu plus que t es de moi j'aime et ça
c'est tous les ingrédients qu'on a
besoin
j'oubliais on chose d'important de lui
on est corps partout on ajoute l'eau et
on mélange tu mets tout ramassé ma
farine me concentre à bien propre et je
vois que ma patte
elle est belle elle est assez collante
le résultat final c'est le pâte assez
humide mais il doit pas attacher vos
doigts
[Musique]
plon travaillent la pâte plus où elle va
devenir leur dise ça s'appelle
facilement quoi 10 minutes de pétrissage
je dirais dix minutes au haka est déjà
en train d'échanger son visage une fois
la pâte bien pétri on la coupe en deux
puis on l'a couvre dans un contenant
qu'on place 24 heures au réfrigérateur
pour laisser le temps à la levure de
bien faire son travail pendant le
processus de fermentation la levure se
nourrit du sucre et fait lever la patte
de le démontrer ma patte que j'ai fait
hier tous voient comme l'est la double
est déjà et regardons mais délicat doit
elle est vraiment arrêt est vraiment
belle
après environ 24 heures au réfrigérateur
on laisse l'a pas proposé à la
température de la pièce pendant une
heure sur les plaques qu'on aura à
réchauffer au four à 500 degrés on
ajoute un peu d'huile puis la boule de
pâte encore un peu d'huile et en étant
tout simplement et on ajoute la sauce
parce que je vais travailler la pâte est
chez elle à perdu de l'air maintenant
mes pizzas
je les laisse pousser d'impartir le
piège pendant 20 minutes
doucement il va répondre ce terroir et
achetons large de la métropole pour
selon david est le secret de la cuisson
uniforme d'une pizza dans un four
d'investiguer et de la cuire en deux
étapes une première fois avec la sauce
seulement puis avec les garnitures
très souvent quand la piste a fait
maison devait avoir une pâte qui est pas
cuites et une garniture qui est brûlé
pourquoi parce que c'est clair que dans
un four maison
je sais par contre le four de
restaurants en pierres et tout ça quand
j'ai fait cuire la pâte sur une plaque
il faut que ma température va cuire la
pâte au dessus et à l'intérieur avant
que mangane et touré brûle alors comment
on fait pour contourner ce problème on
va un fer de cuisson on va cuire à trois
car la pâte et après quand je vois que
simplement que 5 6 minutes pour cuire
comme il faut la garniture
j'ajoute ma garniture et je veux faire
rire tout ensemble doit aussi beau elle
est parfaite
le quid il est temps maintenant
d'ajouter nos guerriers de sûr préféré
par exemple ici pour une margherita de
la mozzarella fraîche et pour l'autre
pizza quatre fromages du clip maintenant
je vais mettre au four nos paysages pour
notre chacune août à peu près et on va
l'accueillir comme il faut vingt-quatre
heures au frigo une heure à la
température de la pièce 20 minutes de
repos avant de mettre au four deux fois
cinq minutes
il s'agit maintenant de faire vos
propres essais et ajuster ses durée
selon la température et le taux
d'humidité de votre cuisine et de votre
four terminé la marguerite avec lui du
basilic frais les basilic tu vois ses
camardes ferai moi je dirai toujours de
le mettre au point que son préfet
l'huile
voilà un équilibre parfait entre une
croûte et des garnitures cuites à point
[Musique]
- bt tort merci le mariage québec items
l'accueil d'artistes et ça c'est très
bon pour moi